(audience applauding)
- Good evening, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Bird Runningwater,
and I belong to the Cheyenne
and Mescalero Apache tribal nations.
On behalf of the Academy,
and specifically the
Academy's Indigenous Alliance,
it is my privilege to open
tonight's celebrations
by honoring and paying
respect to the Tongva people,
the original caretakers of this water
and land on which we gather.
(audience applauds)
Thank you, Tongva.
We would also like to
honor and pay respect
to the Tataviam and the Chumash people,
an acknowledgement of
the neighboring lands
in which many of our motion
picture community live and work.
Thank you and enjoy your meal.
(audience applauds)
Our program will resume shortly.